foreign
12 years ago I got a accident and had a
spinal cord injury so I'm not able to
move
my legs anymore
within five to ten minutes I could
control my uh hips like they were like
the brain implant picked up what I was
doing with my hips so that was like
yeah the best outcome I think for
everyone I can really build
functional things from it to just an
example I'm training 10 years to stand
up with a friend
having a beer
and that's something I think people
don't realize to walk the brain must
send a command to the region of the
spanner card responsible for the control
of movements
when there is a spinal cord injury this
communication is interrupted
our idea was to re-establish this
communication with a digital Bridge like
an electronic communication between the
brain and the region of the spinal cords
that is still intact that can control
the leg movement we do two different
surgeries there is one surgery at the
level of the brain we do two little
craniotomy put electrodes in order to
record the brain signal and another
surgery at the level of the spinal cord
where we put electrodes on the top of
the spinal cords at the place that is
responsible for leg movements so between
these two there is communication and
electrical communication a digital
bridge that is then reactivated the legs
so when everything is installed the
patient has first to learn how to work
with his brain signals and we also have
to learn how to correlate this brain
signal to the spinal cord stimulation
but this is pretty short in a few
sessions everything is linked and the
patient starts training rapidly garcian
could have evolutional control over the
movement of his paralyzed muscles to
perform movements but of course it took
a lot of training to regain you know
full with brain standing working for
extensive duration
and what we observed
along the duration of this training is a
digital repair of the spinal cord
not only he could leverage the digital
bridge in order to control his paralyze
muscle but also show a recovery of
neurological function yet lost for many
years
suggesting that this digital Bridge also
promote the growth of new nerve
connections